welcome to the program we begin in
afghanistan where the first civilian
flight has just taken off from kabul's
airport since the capital fell to the
taliban last month these are exclusive
pictures of the plane leaving
it's a domestic service bound for the
northern city of mazari sharif
its departure follows repairs to the
runway and radar with the help of
technical teams from qatar
and turkey there it goes taking off now
the first flight let's get more on that
story from charles stratford who joins
us now from kabul and of course
charles we were hearing uh for several
days that technical teams were trying to
get the airport open again with the
airport opens it means
communication really not just
domestically but potentially with the
rest of the world as well
that's right sohail but obviously it's
important to recognize there's a long
way to go yet um we understand that the
the airport was in a terrible state of
disrepair and as you say
we've seen dozens of members of
technical teams from qatar we understand
turkey as well that have been busy over
the last few days getting some of the
fundamentals
in terms of equipment and a radar system
repairing the runway
ready for this yes not insignificant
moment that first domestic flight to the
northern town of
sharif we also know that um
qatar sent a or there was a an a flight
in from qatar today the first in from
qatar there was one in from the uae
yesterday but according to the country
ambassador he's very hopeful that
country ambassador was speaking on the
tarmac um just before that flight took
off very hopeful that uh today signifies
yeah a bit of a a bit of a watershed
and as you say communication with the
outside world is renewed via that
airport of kiosk there's vast amounts of
humanitarian aid that needs to come into
this country the un are estimating that
around half the population of
afghanistan needs urgent humanitarian
aid that's around 20 million people so
it's vital that this good work continues
and that we see obviously those large
planes those c-17s and
c-130s that we've seen that were very
much involved in that evacuation effort
bringing in that vital aid
in the coming days and of course charles
in another story that we're keeping a
very close eye on is a situation north
of the capital in the panshire valley
and conflicting reports about who's
actually in control and who's made gains
that's right things got very messy to
put a a
not too blunt a point on it last night
uh when we heard
certainly from unnamed taliban
commanders reportedly in that area that
the taliban are taking full control of
the panchayat valley that was swiftly
refuted a couple of hours later by
um a video that was leaked to local
media we understand by the former vice
president of ruler salah who we
understand or claims to be inside the
panshir valley he was saying that these
claims by the taliban were in his words
completely baseless and that resistance
would continue now
uh we know that the valley is is very
easy or is very well defended sorry by
this opposition group to the taliban we
also according to the taliban say they
they say that they have fully surrounded
the area the big concern is for what we
understand are around 150 to 200 000
civilians that are inside the valley
um mainly from a tajik the tagic ethnic
minority
we got very close to the entrance
yesterday
we spoke to civilians in that area and
the taliban and this is our report
smoke rises over the town of gulbahar
the entrance to the panchir valley in
northeast afghanistan
neither the soviets during the 1980s war
nor the taliban have ever managed to
control this mountainous region around
100 kilometers north of kabul
a shell lands nearby
taliban fighters ready their weapons
men in this village say they have driven
their wives and children to safety they
are angry and scared
the americans betrayed us president
ghani betrayed us too
you left us under the cannons and tanks
and we can't stop either side fighting
how much can they kill their brothers
how much can they kill their fellow
afghans
they have to stop fighting
the taliban drive american military
vehicles and pick up trucks taking
fighters to and from the front line
thousands of men like these across
afghanistan have known little else but
conflict and war all their lives
the fighting started three days ago now
we've taken a lot of areas up there by
the antenna we have no issue with the
civilians we are here to defend their
rights people are staying in their homes
the national resistance front of
afghanistan or nrf is believed to be
several thousand strong and made up of
mainly ethnic tajik fighters and former
afghan army soldiers the group is led by
this man ahmed masood
he's british military academy trained
and the son of ahmed sharmasood who
fought against the soviets and the
taliban and was assassinated by al-qaeda
two days before the 9 11 attacks in
2001.
ahmed massoud is demanding the taliban
form an inclusive government which
guarantees the rights of all
afghanistan's ethnic minorities
including ethnic tajics who make up
around a quarter of the country's
population
the fighting started after two weeks of
negotiations with the taliban collapsed
we have a lot of equipment with
ourselves we will defend from our willy
from our territory until we have one
blood of one drop of blood in our body
so we will resist until we martial in
here taliban fighters edge up a slope
along tracks they say are heavily mined
as we were getting ready to go live
another shell landed close by
the taliban has blocked phone networks
in the valley there are growing fears
about the estimated 150 000 people
living inside and many in taliban
controlled areas around gulbahar
the big concern is that massoud's forces
are coming round on the mountain ridges
trying to surround this area in order to
isolate gulbahar
we left in gulbahar but now we are
leaving
today i came from kabul to collect our
belongings
i already took my family out the
fighting is ongoing there are shells
hitting people's homes both sides are
challenged
afghan families flee for their lives in
one of the last pockets of resistance to
taliban rule
analysts are telling us that they
believe that the nrf are seriously well
armed
they say that uh
that group um or certainly the panchiris
as many people call them have been
stockpiling weapons in the panchi valley
for decades um as we heard there
the panchiris were never taking control
over the valley was never controlled by
the soviets nor the taliban speaking to
locals yesterday in that area it was
interesting they were saying that they'd
seen a lot of weapons go into the valley
in and around the days of when the
taliban came into kabul so they were
very much prepared
but also to be remembered is the fact
that they are massively outnumbered by
the taliban so yeah
huge ramifications for the civilian
population
in and around that area and also very
interesting as well people that we've
been speaking to we've been obviously
speculating as to when this new taliban
government will be formed and
announcements on that well many experts
saying they don't expect potentially any
new government to be announced until the
panshir fighting is over
because so they say they want the the
taliban want to be seen as fully
inclusive and of course there is a lot
of ethnic tashicks in that area so yeah
that conflict 100 or so kilometers north
of kabul has huge ramifications not only
with respect to a humanitarian level and
the suffering of thousands of people but
you know the political future of this
country and of course we'll continue to
monitor what happens there north of the
capital with you charles stratford in
kabul thank you